chris brockman do you remember how
morris the player how much i do remember
him remember chris sabo
remember barry larkin yeah remember jim
you remember
absolutely uh do you remember derek
jeter oh i know i know what you're doing
now it took me a while what do these
people all have in common they went to
the university of michigan well derek
didn't he was going to but you know he
had a hall of fame perfect
career you claim him anyway for for
michigan
hello because of intent
yes and i claim this man san diego may
claim this man but i claim him
[Laughter]
i claim this man i claim this man the
amount of delight he gave me watching
them go on this run or maybe come so
close to it in college world series
title in 2019
and then watching him do what he's doing
right now for the san diego padres
uh we're not talking about fernando
tatis junior or manny machado we're
talking about jake friggin kroningworth
who's right here on the rich show how
are you jake how's that for an
introduction
i'm doing great how are you guys yeah
you're doing awesome i will say that
you are doing awesome how how how are
you how about that how are you doing
jake cronin worth
man i'm great this is uh it's been an
awesome homestay
and an awesome year so far and i'm just
happy there's four crowds back in the
stadium right
that must be and it's just you know uh
just
seeing the the crowds back in and seeing
how people
are are in the stands watching you and
the rest of your teammates and how
thrilled they are to see how you are
performing
what is it like to bat in between tatis
and manny machado
jake what is that like i don't know it's
uh i don't know whose idea it was to put
me there
i don't even know if i belong in that
spot but uh it's been pretty special
those two guys are pretty special to
play with too so
well i mean awesome look i mean you you
were put there
that's a serious responsibility it
stretches the lineup obviously it
extends the lineup
and plus you know you're needing to
protect somebody in front of you who's
protecting
you know uh the person behind you as
well
so what what uh what do you what have
you seen better pitches what what has it
been like
for you jake uh i think the biggest
difference is
you know when the lineup's a little more
spread out and it's lefty ready lefty
righty
you know maybe you might get one extra
righty out of that bullpen
um to face toddy and manny but
um and maybe see one less lefty so
that's really the only difference
you know guys are pitching how they're
gonna pitch in today's game and i think
that's
you know kind of how the whole league's
doing now and uh
what is it like uh in your clubhouse
these days
um performing obviously you're you're
you're in a very deep end of a pool
in the national league west uh what do
you guys talk about
when you you think of your common goals
do you guys talk world series like
openly
in your clubhouse jake um you know i
wouldn't say openly
you know we have have some guys in our
team who've been there and and won the
world series so they know what it takes
but
um you know i think i think everybody's
goal is just to win each day
and um you know if we're playing our
best
our best baseball at the end of the year
i think uh everybody knows what we can
do
all right i've been dancing around the
question that i really want to ask you
straight up jake kronerworth
how does going to the greatest
institution of higher learning on planet
earth helped you in becoming a major
league baseball
star jake how does that help you know
what up i'll tell you this
i get a lot of crap about it in the
locker room because i'm one of the only
guys on the team that
went to college uh but i try to tell
them
michigan is the greatest place to ever
exist so right um
you know guys they'll have to experience
it for themselves someday
well i mean where why would you get crap
for
going to michigan jake i don't know i
don't i don't get it because i talk
about it a lot and i think
a lot of people who do go to michigan
talk about it a lot because it is so
great
yeah that's why we annoy people jake
i mean that's that's why we annoy
everybody when we talk about how
uh terrific it is um but uh
they give you crap for it in your
clubhouse a little bit
a little bit you know hmm but i mean
i guess in all seriousness then how did
your your run
to the college world series title help
you prepare for these moments
for you right now well i i
actually wasn't on that team i was on
the team at 15
that won the big ten championship right
uh
and then uh we ended up losing in the
region of louisville
so you that's right super special so you
you
you closed out did you close out a big
ten championship jake did you
like get on the mound and close one out
back the day not
[Music]
pen available jace tingler hand you the
baseball at some point in time
i like to think that can uh i think i
might need a couple months to get ready
to
be back to like what i was and when i
was pitching in 2019
um but i think if uh
if we had nobody left and it was the
last resort i think i could do it come
on now
how how how fast could you touch right
now jake if giving the ball right now
oh i don't know about right now um
i would like to say in the low to mid
90s but
i don't know okay um jake cronin worth
here
uh on the rich eisen show uh how much do
you enjoy homering off of trevor bauer
how was that question
what do you think i enjoy homering
whenever i can because i
i don't get too many of them but uh you
know those guys are really good so
any chance you can hit a homer off a
really good arm
it's always fun okay i like that you're
that's a very high road answer
i appreciate that but it does it does
seem to me
though that your team relishes the
competition against the los angeles
dodgers would that be a safe assumption
100 yeah they're a really good team
you know whenever we play them both
teams are bringing their a game
and uh i feel like every game we play
against them it's a one-run game in the
ninth
and somebody's on base and the tying or
winning runs at the plate and
you know somebody's always making a big
play on either side so
uh okay what are you guys talking about
in your clubhouse these days jay
cronenworth of the san diego padres here
on the rich eisen show
what are you guys talking about in your
clubhouse these days about the pictures
being
checked for all these substances
what's the what's the general sense of
what you and your teammates
it's a crazy time in our game and you
know
the league made the decision this past
monday to check the pictures when
they're coming off and
you know it's just kind of where we're
at you know different guys have
different opinions on it and
you know it's just one of those things i
don't know how long it's going to last
but um for right now this is kind of the
state of our game what is your opinion
on it jake
yeah i was you know good and bad
you know i think uh you know guys
throughout the history baseball have
been using it and um
you know that's really it i mean you
know now
i think maybe guys took it a little too
far and we're kind of out where we are
now but
um you know i'm sure we'll try to do
something to even the playing field out
here in the future in the next couple
years
so uh how do you feel as a hitter then
jake
because the the you know we've heard
from pete alonso of the mets we've heard
from others
or saying let let some of these guys
have something
because i don't want to get hit by a
pitch
do you ascribe to that j chronowood um
you know i guess i've never really
thought about it like that um
where guys we're using it to maybe not
hit guys but
uh you know i will say some guys pitches
have been really really good this year
and
[Music]
pitchers have been really good and i
think that's a testament to them too
just getting really good in the off
season
but uh we'll see how now that they're
getting checked and they're not allowed
to use it how their stuff
turns out for the rest of the season jay
cronenworth here
on the rich eisen show um how much
better do you think you can get jake
what do you need to improve on what do
you what do you take that approach what
do you got for me there
you know i think the biggest thing for
me you know during the year
and during the off season is just
getting as good as i can on the
defensive side of the ball
um we got a really good starting
pitching staff and a really good bullpen
so anything i can do to help those guys
out as much as i can
to keep us in a game that's that's kind
of my main goal
okay and then uh wearing that chain as
much as possible
jake how heavy is that thing however is
that uh
it looks heavier or it is heavier than
it actually looks
it's uh is that right it's pretty heavy
no kidding so is that solid
gold or something like that or is it
that i don't know what's in it i haven't
asked what's in it
okay but it is it is pretty heavy is it
the hood ornament on manny machado's car
is that what that is you could
afford that with his latest contract or
tatis i mean
is that is that what that is
i think i think they can afford it okay
who picks up the tab for dinner
now that maybe you're you're going to
start doing that sort of thing who does
that
with you guys who does that well if i
had to guess you know
tatissa's got the biggest contract so i
think he's on the hook for that one come
on now does he have does he have is that
where he
he is he like that geico commercial or
he's got the
alligator arms reaching for the check
i think i know manny and heisman said
something about it earlier before the
season when he signed it
you know he's picking up that check now
that he's got the biggest contract so
[Music]
okay now hold on i just i i was unaware
about this fact it just was whispered
into my ear by
uh my producer mike hoskins did you
strike out mookie bets earlier this year
jake
did that happen did you get on the mound
and do that
did that happen i did yeah what
happened see you've got you still can do
it you've got it
right well it was uh actually in a game
i think it was the 12th inning of
of uh the second game we played him this
year yes
and corey seeger had let off the inning
with the two run homer
and then somebody else had hit a an rbi
double
um so they had gone up three or four
runs
and we we had no pitching left for the
we just been because we played a super
close game the night before we had no
pitching the rest of that game
so we had a mom visit and i'm looking in
the bullpen and nobody was getting up
and they just said hey you're in the
game you're pitching
that was the first guy the first guy
grounded out to first base
and i forgot to cover first base so he
got a hit
and then david price ended up hitting a
sac fly off of me
right and then me not covering first
base allowed me to face mookie
and i ended up striking him out how
what'd you strike him out on you
remember
uh just the sinker i think he was a
little surprised that i threw
yeah you got cause you had that in your
bag you didn't think you had that in
your back
there's no scouting report on you right
not going to the pictures i mean that
time there wasn't so it's been a it's
been two years since i pitched so
okay all right so you're deep in your
bag man
i like it all right that's great that
did you strut off the mountain like
bauer at least or no you did you stare
him down did you give him a little stare
little girardi stare down little smack
sure i asked for the ball from
victor carrantini immediately because i
knew i wanted that thing
where's the ball now is it home you got
it the ball
no the ball is in my locker
authenticated everything
damn straight get mookie to sign it
he's trying to beat him he's trying to
beat him that's still cool
he's trying to beat him you're trying to
be otani of the national league he's
what you're trying to do
that's a challenge i know that guy's
that guy is unbelievable right i mean
and and i guess again front row seat in
terms of what
how you got a good feeling here i mean
because it just i it comes through the
television set
you know slam diego you know uh and then
this
year it just feels like you guys have
some momentum with the padres jake
quite frankly yeah we're playing playing
really good right now i think
we had a really tough road trip before
we came back home
uh this this past weekend against the
reds
and then that first night opening
opening i guess reopening night with all
the full stadium
hosmer hits the game tying to run homer
and then karentini hits a walk-off
two-run homer
i think that just kind of jump-started
everything for us
[Music]
would it be provocative to have the the
victors as a walk-up song to the plate
jake or is that too
is that too provocative in major league
baseball i'll tell you this
i don't even need to have it as a
walk-up song about
once or twice a home stand after one of
my hits go play the
the victors through the stadium after
one of my hits that's
great this is great we just need to win
it against ohio state and then we're
fine
oh man i was hoping you said that
that's all we need we just got it one
november oh the amount of crap that i
take man because the nfl the nfl is
filled with
players from the ohio state and it is a
it's been a rough go of it for me jake i
know
i don't mean to complain and [ __ ] and
wine to you and now our strength coach
for our team went to ohio state so i
hear about all the time
please oh
jake this has been a pleasure let's chat
down the road
you know um absolutely it really is a
pleasure watching you play and be the
the michigan man at this major league
that you and rich hit you and rich hill
rich is killing it he's killing it right
now so you guys keep doing what you're
doing
uh very proud to watch you do it so
thanks for the call jake
awesome thanks richard i appreciate you
having me on any time let's do this
again that's jake cornerworth he's
raking for the san diego padres
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here